frédéric toute cette histoire illustre
bien la problématique de la gestion des
déchets est un problème mondial en fait
regarder un chiffre qui parle beaucoup
céline en 2016 on a produit 2 milliards
de tonnes de déchets sur la planète
c'est énorme
et si la tendance se maintient en 2050
on va passer à 3 milliards 400 millions
tonnes c'est énorme évidemment ça
représente une augmentation d'à peu près
70 % ça commence à devenir assez
ingérable d'autant plus que tout cette
gestion de déchets produits plus d'un
milliard 600 millions de tonnes de gaz à
effet de serre ça quand on regarde
l'enveloppent totale des gaz à effet de
serre ça représente environ 5% ce qui
est quand même assez inquiétant parce
qu'il ya vraiment une hausse maintenant
qui produit le plus justement de ces
déchets les regarder en millions de
tonnes c'est l'asie
l'asie est et pacifique 468 millions de
tonnes est à peu près un quart
évidemment on a tous le volume de l'asie
ici au niveau de la population c'est
normal on arrive en quatrième position
en amérique du nord avec 289 millions de
tonnes maintenant ce qu'il faut
surveiller c'est que on aura de plus en
plus de deux pays qui sont riches et
plus on est riche plus on produit
figurez-vous des déchets il ya une
corrélation assez évidente
un exemple par exemple des pays à
revenus élevés qui représente à peu près
16 % de la population mondiale
regardez au niveau de la production
déchets c'est 34% de l'ensemble de la
planète ça c'est inquiétant
et quand on regarde la tendance aussi
pour les prochaines années on remarque
qu'il ya une tendance se dessine 2050 il
ya deux régions du monde l'afrique
subsaharienne et l'asie du sud qui elles
vont tripler et doubler leur production
déchets ça c'est inquiétant parce que ce
sont des régions qui ne seront pas très
bien outillé justement pour gérer ce
genre de problème
donc on produit trop de déchet toutes
sortes des déchets oui toutes sortes
effectivement d'abord quand on parle des
déchets organiques et déchets
alimentaires
c'est là la plus grosse portion en fait
des déchets produits on arrive ici
environ 44 % de l'ensemble des tonnes de
déchets ensuite ce sont les papiers et
les cartons qui arrive en deuxième
position avec 17% et 3e place évidemment
c'est la plus problématique ce sont les
fameux plastique donc ils ne sont pas du
tout bio dégradable donc 12%
maintenant tous ses déchets ou sans
vente il ou est ce qu'on les retrouve 1
37%
on les enfui à 33% on les met dans les
décharges
l'ouver 19% seulement de recyclage et
11%
on les as in her beaucoup de chiffres
alarmants merci fallait qu'ils ont pris